So it was sort of novelty from last week was
Donald Trump's son in law showing off to a
White House corona virus?
Press briefing with Donald Trump and Jared
Kushner.
Is Donald Trump's slumlord son in law married
to a bunkered Trump, son of convicted felon
Charles Kushner?
And Jared Kushner thinks he can manage his
way to success no matter what the challenge
he was put in charge of solving the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict for Donald Trump.
You probably have some idea of how well that's
going so far.
So Kushner shows up at a press conference
last week and his presence is completely sinister
in nature.
I actually posted a poll on my Twitter page
asking who disturbs you more by being at the
White House press briefings and by just a
massive margin, about 18000 people voted.
It was Kushner by a long shot, 78 to 22.
Kushner more disturbing than the my pillow
guy.
And I have to say, I totally agree that my
pillow guy was the religious nut Trump supporting
brownnoser, but he's at least just trying
to make some masks for health care workers.
Jared Kushner is involvement in the Corona
virus response is actually downright ominous.
So let's look at one clip from Kushner.
We'll look at another clip in a second segment.
Jared was asked about all of the state governors
who have been asking for ventilators.
They've been asking for masks and other supplies.
And not all of them have been getting them.
And Jared Kushner pulls some sort of total
management consulting mumbo jumbo about how
the federal stockpile is our stockpile, not
for the states.
And of course, the question is, who is us?
Like when he says the federal stockpile is
for us?
Who are the people that he's referring to?
Take a look at this.
Completely UNINTELLIGIBLE sinister, depraved
clip.
And you have instances where in cities they're
running out, but the state still has a stockpile.
And the notion of the federal stockpile was
supposed to be our stockpile.
It's not supposed to be state stockpiles that
they then use.
So we're encouraging the states to make sure
that they're assessing the needs.
They're getting the data from their local
US local situations and then trying to fill
it with the supplies that we've given them.
The same thing with the masks.
The notion of the federal stockpile was it's
supposed to be our stockpile, not the state
stockpiles that they then use.
So, of course, it's supposed to be our stockpile
is our and us being who doesn't everyone live
in one of the states?
Like is he saying the stockpile is only for
people who live in D.C., Puerto Rico, Guam?
Like, what does it mean that it's for us and
not for the states?
Who is the stockpile for?
It's a sinister, ominous Orwellian explanation.
And you know how you can tell that Jared messed
up here because the next day Donald Trump
was asked about it.
And when he was asked about it, he told the
reporter that they should be ashamed of themselves.
When Donald Trump tells a reporter, you should
be ashamed of yourself.
It means it's a good question.
It means Trump's up against the wall and it
means Trump is trying to defend the indefensible.
Check this out.
From the day after Jared Kushner said the
no federal stockpile was supposed to be our
stockpile.
It's not supposed to be state stockpiles.
Hey, there he is.
What did you hear?
What's that got to do with our, you know,
our image?
United States of America?
That's what it means.
It means our hours.
It means the United States of America.
And then we take that hour and we distribute
it to the states, not to be state stockpiles,
because we needed for the government and we
needed for the federal government.
But when the states are in should know to
also keep that state to keep to keep for a
country, because the federal government needs
to not just the states, but out of that, we
oftentimes choose as an example, we have almost
10000 ventilators and we are ready to rock
with those ventilators.
We're going to bring them to various areas
of the country that need them.
But when he shows our he's talking about our
country.
He's talking.
Excuse me.
He's talking about the federal government.
I mean, it's such a basic, simple question.
And you try and make it sound so bad to be
you ought to be ashamed of yourself.
You know what he would appreciate if such
a simple question, how shameful for a reporter
to ask about a completely incoherent statement
from someone.
Jared Kushner, who has no business whatsoever
managing the response to a virus pandemic.
Trump is doing the same thing by.
Way ours means the U.S. stockpile, not the
state stockpile.
So we give the stockpile to states, which
Jared said we aren't doing because we need
the stockpile for the federal government.
What the stockpile is to treat federal government
employees like, what on earth is it that they
are arguing here?
And then now we get to the really Orwellian
twist right after Jared Kushner said this
last week.
It's our stockpile, not the states.
The national stockpile Web site was changed
before Jared Kushner's delusional comment.
The stockpile website said the stockpile is
the nation's largest supply of life-saving
pharmaceuticals and medical supplies for use
is in an emergency that causes local supplies
to run out when states request assistance.
The stockpile ensures they get what they need.
That's what it said before Jared Kushner's
sinister Orwellian statement after Kushner
statement.
The website was immediately changed and it
now simply says the stockpile is to supplement
state supplies.
Many states have stockpiles.
This can be a stopgap buffer if states don't
immediately have everything available.
A much softer view on the role of the stockpile
for states.
Jared Kushner, ladies and gentlemen, a sinister
Orwellian journal voiced lunatic at these
press briefings has no business whatsoever
being there.
And I actually have one more Jared Kushner
clip to talk about here